c'est une semaine éprouvante
rationnellement
vous avez vécu pied jusqu'au les
nombreux à vous appeler pour vous
demander comme si vous étiez à sa
chambre parce qu'elle est morte parce
qu'elle est morte il avoua effectivement
de plus en plus de gens seraient les
réseaux sociaux et dans la rue qui
m'arrêtent et qui maintenant des
bertrand comment va la syrie nous alors
je sais pas encore mais de ça mais avec
tpm paix vous faites aussi des pmp toute
la semaine très souvent avec cyril
bougaux vous retourne en belgique qu'est
ce que les gens vous disent ils sont un
peu un peu hystérique de joie parce que
pour eux bah oui c'est un peu comme une
rock-star maintenant là bas en belgique
gérons rila ouais mais c'est vrai que
c'est très regardée cp mp3 ça demain
dans la rue on vous arrête vous
demandent des photos on parle de titre
de cyril vous disent qu'il est gentil
cyril on ne va pas parler de la reine
non qu'est ce que vous répondez avec les
jantes et cyril bourelly la coupe arabe
cyril hanouna oui c'est ça que je vous
ai a fait la couleur ça c'est un signe
quand on fait la couleur c'est qu'on
commence à être connu non on commence à
gagner un peu d'argent à vous tous c'est
pas ça c'est un vrai dire qu'ils
représentent en fin de compte ils
représentaient belgique avec une
émission française ouais
ils seront connus en belgique donc qui
représente à la population belge avec
une émission
mais quand tu as peu tu peut être parce
que c'est chaud quand même tu vois ce
gentil avec man 2 qui est là qui bien
sûr est le chauffeur du stade de tpm
paix cette semaine on l'a aidé à
l'honneur
cellules de garde pour lui c'est la star
des chauffeurs de salle oui pardon non
je pose une question pour revenir sur la
red sea lion qui sont que personne n'a
sans doute comment elle a pu choper le
covin
question personne n'a posé mais elle à
96 ans qui appelle approchés ils soient
pas tester ses proches à qui le fuit
j'avais des cas la semaine à san mamés
mais le site est
éventuellement s'il n'y a pas besoin de
faire rentrer son amadio elle est chef
de l'église anglicane le jour où elle
rejoindra dieu son dieu eh ben le sun
parle de matricide ce serait un
matricide pourquoi le père qui aurait
tué la mère charles a fait près du filet
mais non là est devenu un rôle voilà
c'est le sun qui qui laisse prétend sera
donc à 73 ans est quand même mérité le
mieux préparé du monde et leur public
n'entend jamais exercé vraiment son
métier donc voilà ayant aussi une pensée
pour charles qui semble peut-être lui
considéré que l'heure est venue à une
porte c'est vous qui
dites ou tuer sa mère jeudi que voilà
forcément c'est humain finale commune à
quelque 96 ans de prison comme il ne l'a
pas fait exprès en revanche ce qui peut
dire en effet c'est qu'il y à encore don
de sécurité qui pour le coup a manqué de
vigilance autour d'elizabeth ii c'est
une excellente question parce qu'elle
convainc royal bubble qui est composé de
11 personnes sont fait donc 22 et
normalement ces deux équipes là pourquoi
sont-elles deux parce que pendant qu'une
équipe et tester l'autre officie auprès
des malades est de donc on veille à ce
que l'entourage proche ne soit jamais
contaminée par le coroner il ya eu une
défaillance à charm et vous rendez vous
comme que le coup le pochât si on est
très honnête ça fait soixante dix ans
soixante dix ans qu'il attend les trois
à 113 73 ans qu'ils attendaient 3
maintenant on va fêter ce but est de 70
ans commence à bien faire 73 oui mais
depuis qu'il est né il sait qu'un jour
il deviendra roi mais c'est logique
c'est pas impossible qu'ils meurent
avant l onil à quel âge et il dut quel
âge at il va s'en mêler jamais
ça arrive mais ça voudrait dire que du
coup williams et s'est discrètement de
refiler le coc vide à ça
gâtés à s'en aller contaminé le calme il
ya les comptes annuels à la reine est
contaminé on peut parler d'un cluster
windsor alors maintenant soit un petit
peu sérieux même si tout ça est très
sérieux parce que je ne sens pas le
charles qu'est-ce qui se passe si demain
la reine meure eh bien écoutez c'est
véritablement une opération militaire et
elle porte un nom de code presque
militaire le london bridge core et cette
opération militaire on la connaît en
détail depuis septembre 2021 nous sommes
à nouveau pour ne pas le citer a réussi
à se procurer les douze pages d'un
rapport hyper précis donc dans le
moindre détail on sait exactement ce qui
va arriver le jour du décès s'appellera
d'ailleurs lui david ludivine qui est en
ont aussi très militant voilà et alors
effectivement elle a déjà est ce que
c'est vrai que chaque membre de la
famille royale a le nom d'un pont au cas
où il meurt porte en effet le nom d'un
pont se souvient que pour le prince
philip qui était duc d'edimbourg c'était
le fork bridge qui est un pont qui est à
edimbourg et pour la reine mère par
exemple c'était le tabloïd jamais assez
de ponts en angleterre pour toute la
famille a beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
ponts en tout cas pourquoi le pont
mathieu parce que ça symbolise l'eau le
passage entre deux rives y voir
absolument
l'anecdote
lors de ses obsèques et bien il y avait
donc son le nom de code qui était donc
décrété que je viens de donner et il a
été utilisé pour les obsèques de diana
prend 97 puisque personne ne s'attendait
à ce que diana mort subite donc j'ai
pris ma réponse voilà des mois de
répétitions vraiment on a eu beau but
c'est le nom que là-bas
mais tu as raison
même si c'est tout comme tu as raison la
coïncidence est la paix demeure sous le
pont de l'alma
comme chez comme c'est plus que pour
laisser les moulineaux non mais 8 ch qui
à la base était difficile et boulay nos
marques voilà tout sauf de la rigolade
il ya des la raison c'est une sage
jamais en fait à ça
les pétitions régulièrement qui sont
orchestrées dans les moindres faits et
gestes est par exemple la bbc sait
parfaitement où elle va positionner ses
caméras déjà sous les voûtes de
westminster et pour encore la petite
anecdote les caméras seront d'ailleurs
enveloppes paix maintenant la donne dans
elmer nouvelles moeurs qui n'annoncent
qu'il annonce alors le premier à
l'annoncer va être l'associate presse
qui est vraiment le grand organisme qui
gère les médias à ses parents mais nous
en angleterre annoncée par le premier
ministre c'est vraiment la presse
d'accord va prendre le relais le premier
ministre en revanche sera avec le prince
charles l'un des premiers à être au
courant il sera appelé directement sur
une ligne privée par le secrétaire de la
reine il recevra ce nom de code lan de
l'agglo is down like qu'est ce qui va se
passer pendant dix jours époux plus à
bien ça va être extraordinaire la
première opération en quelques sortes va
être de rapatrier la dépouille et si
l'on peut dire il ya de fortes chances
qu'elles s'éteignent à windsor qui est
désormais son lieu de où elle vit en
permanence et cette opération va saper
l'opération licorne ont besoin de noms
pour tous
genres et bien à tous on va ressortir le
trac royal avec la voiture funèbres qui
n'a plus été utilisé depuis 1952 le
corps va être ramené à londres en commun
qu'est le démarrage jour il va être
exposée dans la salle du trône du palais
de buckingham où seule la famille proche
d'accord un membre du personnel pour
mener leur déroute en même temps quand
même alors elle a intérêt à 2 ans 3 au
bout de leur siège en jeu 10 des plus 10
mais voilà baladé pendant dix jours
n'entend absolument pas elles restent
les six premiers jouent aux fins palais
de buckingham pendant ce tournage le
prince charles va déjà visité l'irlande
du nord l'ecosse et le pays de galles où
il va recevoir officiellement les
zonages rappelons qu il fera déjà devenu
roi à la seconde où il isabelle mère
survient et oded et +6 la dépouille
alors est ramenée à westminster hall qui
est l'endroit où siègent les deux
chambres à londres et là c'est fascinant
parce que oui ce ministère hall 1500 m²
une salle construite en l'an 1000 cas
d'un désaccord et pendant trois jours et
trois nuits plus exactement pendant 23
heures la population anglaise va pouvoir
venir sakhnin est d'accord
avant avant avant qu'elles soient
d'accord pendant les cinq jours j'ai
compris il paraît qu'à une parade il va
y avoir une belle c'est quoi ça va pas
être une parade non non ça va être en
hommage entre le moment où la bouddhiste
c'est quoi la ccl quoi et la dépouille
va quitter le palais de buckingham pour
rejoindre donc oui mr wolf et sera
probablement sur un afflux de canon est
en effet il va y avoir alors des zonages
qui vont être rendus tout ça est rédigé
déjà tous à vérifier tout ça rip type
régulièrement la ligue 1 voilà une nuit
pour le coup ça se fait pendant la nuit
pour comme un business pour le coup la
parade ses réponses pénales parce que on
voit le mal le maniement des choses et
sachez qu'au quart de ces dix jours
membres et m'en fous la famille royale
va aussi se livrer à une répétition en
l'abbaye de westminster pour savoir
précisément qui va être positionné à
quel endroit on peut peut-être aussi
dire que d'un point de vue militaire et
stratégique ça va être terrible pour
londres puisque tous les chefs d'état du
monde entier doit être présenté je
raconte tout le côté tout comme en
extra je crois qu'il a de la livre mais
là vraiment c'était passionnant je crois
qu'en sprint comme dit bertrand et
devait être enterré tout simplement où
lé lé lé empaillés
modifier voire national
ta tête tu n'as cheminée
a
déjà tous les détails sur le cercueil ça
donne aux messieurs j'ai entendu à la
peau mais avec mémé et le fameux
cercueil a été choisi il ya déjà de
nombreuses manières dont les indices à
remontrer aux années 60 et déjà c'est un
chèque ça cercueil en chêne anglais et
en plomb pelle a essayé moi ça c'est pas
bien mais ça valait 2 ont été réalisés
alors les a mis là je crois qu'on a eu
tort pas de danse et pas mylène farmer
dont six à pascal mais je crois que dans
tous les cas merci je suis désolé
bertrand c'est compliqué mais c'était
très intéressant je voudrais vous pas
vous passer le week-end ici oui mais je
ne quitte plus je n'appartiens s'amuse à
poser une dernière question
vous savez ce que ça veut dire c'est
qu'on passera au sujet d'al hira gasy et
en gros dans tout ça à bas la semaine on
parle de jennifer aniston et brad pitt
[Applaudissements]